[Musique]
c'est une vénérable dame de pierre
immense et imposante la cathédrale de
bourges chef-d'oeuvre de l'art gothique
a traversé sept siècles d'histoire
construite en plein coeur de la ville
c'est devenu au fil du temps le symbole
de la cité bon les amis commencent à
vous passer au tour à cathédrale s'il
vous plaît n'oubliez pas de vous mettre
aussi derrière l'église basse c'est très
important son consentement
tout autour cette année les berruyers
fête les 25 ans du classement au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco d'une
drôle de façon
ils forment une chaîne humaine pour
faire un gros câlin à la cathédrale
certains sont venus en famille ou entre
amis pour fêter cet anniversaire
original et sympa main dans la main les
habitants mais aussi les scouts et les
associations sportives ont répondu
présent approchez vous approchez vous
sera coupée là on va y arriver on va y
arriver à l'aller
ça va aller ni thuraya lettre on va
tenir c'est bon une manifestation
populaire qui a reçu le soutien du
diocèse comme on dit c'est un petit peu
décalé mais sa marque l'attachement des
gens à leur cathédrale et ce cas-là
cette marque voilà de l'attachement est
une bonne chose je pense et ça permet de
fédérer d'ouvrir largement à tout le
monde qu'on soit croyant ou pas on est
attaché au patrimoine de la ville et à
cette cathédrale encore pour que
l'événement soit un succès il fallait
rassembler 500 personnes minimum
pari réussi pour cet anniversaire
monumental non non non non c'est un
petit peu compliqué là mais je pense
qu'on a réussi à faire le tour par là
pour la symbolique c'est important ce
très important
il ya aussi la transmission des savoirs
il ya des jeunes nous c'est bien c'est
très bien
beaucoup d'amour pour un si beau
monument super extra
[Musique]
et c'est bon on est parti à une plaque
officielle a été dévoilée en l'honneur
de ce quart de siècle placé sous l'égide
de l'unesco le texte gravé rédigeant 92
et particulièrement élogieux elle a été
reconnue en tant que chef d'oeuvre du
génie créateur humain du fait de sa
beauté frappante d'un espace aux
proportions harmonieuses et de son
importance dans le développement de l'
architecture gothique probablement par
modestie nous n'avons pas toujours mis
en avant cette reconnaissance au
caractère exceptionnel et la ville de
bourges ne figure pas pour l'instant à
sa juste place sur la carte du tourisme
patrimonial
l'hommage se poursuit avec la parution
d'un ouvrage collectif la grâce d'une
cathédrale une trentaine d'historiens
chercheurs prêtres ou simples passionnés
ont participé à la rédaction de ce livre
comme les usages dans cette collection
est le dédicace à l'intérieur de
l'édifice religieux
et certains n'hésitent pas à en acheter
plusieurs pour toute la famille mon père
bon et bien c'est pas tout ça que je
dois signer là si ce livre accessible au
grand public fait le point sur les
dernières recherches historiques et
dévoile de nouvelles photographies et il
est magnifique
à la fois visuellement j'ai pas encore
vu des textes
si tu veux on est saisi par un ensemble
très très structuré très puissant et
qu'une énergie puis aussi une légèreté a
qu'à voir la lumière l élévation ya un
rapport très fort à la marche et etc tu
râles et humains aussi c'est tout le
monde aime sacré t'aidera et ça c'est
très touchant de voir ça une voûte de 37
mètres de haut
l'absence de transept des vitraux du 13e
siècle font de cet édifice un monument à
part dans l' architecture gothique donc
ici vous l'avez que du vide bien pour en
volume extraordinaire
simplement de pierres dans l'impression
qu'il est très fier
et puis ces colonnes qui s'élance vers
le haut pour la salle de vic sur aisne
est évident quand on arrive je regarde
par de la terre public est au ciel
donc on a
si une cathédrale de lumière une
cathédrale une
visible se déconnecte croyants non
croyants quand on arrive ici il ya
quelque chose qui soit président de
l'association des amis de la cathédrale
berne à brossard fait partie de ces
passionnés j'habite au chevet de la
cathédrale dont tous les matins rajoub
mes volets je vois le chevet de la
cathédrale donc tout ça ça va amener à
m'intéresser à ce bâtiment que je ne
connaissais pas je ne suis pas né à
bourges
mais j'ai je suis tombé immédiatement
amoureux de ce bâtiment pour lui
contrairement à la cathédrale de
chartres le monument n'est pas reconnu à
sa juste valeur par les historiens et le
grand public
pourtant l'association fait éditer des
ouvrages organise des événements comme
la nuit des cathédrales et finance même
la recherche
les amis de canal ont également offert
des bourses à des étudiants pour faire
des études sur la cathédrale de bourges
et je veux réjoui qu'avec les 25 ans de
l'escaut maintenant je pense que les
pouvoirs publics la ville la région
département se sont unis pour enfin
essayer de prendre le problème à bras le
corps essayer de faire en sorte que
cette cathédrale sortent de l'oubli
pour ces festivités olivier sa landini a
décidé de jouer bach
depuis six ans il est l'organiste
titulaire à la cathédrale de bourges
il a donc le privilège de jouer sur le
grand orgue un ouvrage restaurée du
xviie siècle quatre claviers et un
pédalier commandes 3500 tuyaux et 50
registre différent offre des
combinaisons de son infinie lente
extrêmement bien réussi par lui même on
l'entend ici la qualité du son de chaque
tuyau est vraiment travailler vraiment
fini c'est un très beau travail mais
l'acoustique rajoute quelque chose de
vraiment un sublime et c'est une affiche
très rares blancs est très très bien
placée en termes de hauteur la tribune
est assez étroite ce qui ne m'empêche
pas le son de se développer dans la dans
la nef
on peut presque voir le sont les ondes
sonores évoluer la cathédrale et ça
c'est importe énormément tant que miss
cette imprégnation n'y changent en
profondeur ça change aussi de ma manière
de penser la musique manière de jouer à
manière d'écouter
où on écoute non pas seulement l'action
du son mais aussi de la détente
c'est à dire le lâcher et finalement le
lâcher et aussi beau que le sondage que
ne l'attaquent luçon
difficile aujourd'hui d'imaginer le
chantier titanesque de la cathédrale de
bourges commencé au début du xiiie
siècle et s'est poursuivie jusqu'au 15e
même si le gros oeuvre a pris une
trentaine d'années seulement pour yves
gallais historiens la faculté de
bordeaux
la cathédrale de bourges est un
instrument du pouvoir religieux
l'édifice devait se voir de très loin à
plus de 30 km les bâtisseurs de
cathédrales se lance donc dans une
course au gigantisme l'édifice de 37
mètres de haut soit l'équivalent de 12
étages possède une structure
particulièrement audacieuse quand j'ai
débuté mes études sur l'art médiéval et
sur l'architecturé gothique en
particulier je n'avais pas mesuré à quel
point ces cathédrales était particulière
et plus je j je les étudie plus je la
regarde plus son caractère savant me
frappe ce qui la distingue des autres
c'est le fait qu'elle sa structure les
différentes structures
si une structure est échelonné il ya
cinq vaisseaux en largeur les vaisseaux
extérieurs sont un peu plus bas que les
autres
ensuite comme une pyramide si vous
voulez sa s'élève progressivement et 7
une structure qu'on ne retrouve pas dans
les autres
une construction hors norme qui sert
aussi de support aux travaux
pédagogiques
une classe de 5e du collège jean renoir
labellisé l'unesco a travaillé sur ce
thème ou de mathématiques
une façon ludique de faire de la
géométrie dans l'espace sans s'en rendre
compte
donc il y avait deux pavés droit cinq
prises donc ils sont juste là une
tyrannie qui juste là trois morceaux de
caunes qu'on peut voir sur les photos
animalières et 3 de monstres là c'est un
peu impressionnant la rue nous on
n'avait pas du tout cette vision de
plusieurs plusieurs de solides commencé
plusieurs éléments nous la cathédrale
c'était juste le bâtiment un monument
qui a survécu à sept cents ans
d'histoire de réforme de contre-réforme
de révolution et de guerre avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
on bloque l'entrée avec 110 mille sacs
de terre par crainte des bombardements
tous les vitraux sont aussi déposer et
caché en lieu sûr
olivier naulleau professeur agrégé
d'histoire à bourges connais bien cette
période mouvementée
les berruyers on se rendent plus
facilement dans leur cathédrale ils ont
besoin de 2,2 ce lien et à l'époque
évidemment l'archevêque qui prêchent la
ô mon seigneur fillon et bien
s'arrête dans un de ses prêches parce
que j'entends les bruits de bottes des
allemands etc
et puis à la libération le la ville
libérée et bien en fait l'événement à la
cathédrale
nous descendons dans l'église dite
souterraine située à quelques pas de la
crypte c'est ici que se trouvent les
tombeaux des anciens évêques
car à l'origine la cathédrale n'étaient
pas construites pour les fidèles il faut
pas oublier que une cathédrale c'est
d'abord l'église d'année avec un
cathèdre c'est le siège le trône de
l'évêque et donc depuis le début du 19e
siècle
ils sont tous enterrés ici autour de
nous des messes sont célébrées tous les
jours à la cathédrale avant chaque
office le prêtre qui savent se prépare
dans la sacristie
c'est le vestiaire des prêtres et des
chanoines chaque couleur de chasubles
correspond à un temps d'église et ça
commence avec le temps de l'avent nous
prenons la couleur violette et c'est
aussi la couleur utilisée pour le temps
du carême qui précède les 40 jours qui
précèdent pâques pâques et les grands
fête du christ ou de la vierge
la couleur est blanche doré et puis pour
toutes les fêtes de la passion du christ
de la mort du christ ou des martyrs qui
ont ceux qui ont versé leur sang pour au
nom de la foi au christ et bien c'est la
couleur est rouge vous qu'il y a une
couleur pour différentes fêtes les
différentes circonstances de l'église
d'abord étudiant en théologie au vatican
chef de choeur puis curé de campagne
il n'imaginait pas devenir un jour
l'archiprêtre de la cathédrale avant la
révolution française
il y avait une partie de l'allier une
petite partie du loiret
donc c'était vraiment un grand diocèse
ç'a toujours été territorialement le
plus grand de france
une fonction prestigieuse mais pour lui
cela ne change pas grand chose
la prière est la même que l'on soit dans
la nature que l'on soit dans une petite
chapelle de campagne conçoit la
cathédrale le contact puisque si une
rencontre le contact avec dieu se se
déroule de la même manière et pour
faciliter ce lien religieux
il y à la lumière des verrières avec une
centaine de fenêtres répartis sur trois
niveaux
cette cathédrale possède une des
collections les plus anciennes et les
plus importantes de vitraux
saint-guillaume architecte de la
cathédrale il ya lui-même représenter le
bien et le mal le paradis ou les flammes
de l'enfer
ces vitraux propager la morale
chrétienne du moyen-âge ce sont des
illustrations des paraboles ou des
sacrements de l'église pour bien les
comprendre il faut avoir en tête une
double lecture celle de l'ancien et du
nouveau testament
[Musique]
ce lieu religieux accueille aussi de
nombreux concerts pour le printemps de
bourges ou pour des occasions
exceptionnelles
pour clore les festivités de ce 25e
anniversaire
les quarante choristes de la troupe
microcosmos qu'on chantait dans la
cathédrale dans un lieu aussi puissant
architecturalement c'est toujours
impressionnant
après c'est un vaisseau qui nous dépasse
un peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sept siècles après la construction de la
cathédrale de bronze le temps est venu
de la protection de cette vénérable dame
de pierre
[Musique]
et